what we have depicted here in these four
images are matter in different states
and we're using what's known as a
particulate model and these are
two-dimensional particulate models which
are simple ways of imagining what is
going on at a molecular scale inside of
matter and so you can imagine each of
these circles - depending on what we're
dealing with it's either an ion it's a
molecule or it's an atom but it's
telling us how these molecules or ions
or atoms are interacting with each other
which determine what state of matter we
are in so pause this video and think
about which of these quadrants represent
matter in a solid state which represent
matter in a liquid state and which
represents matter in a gas state alright
so there's a few that might have been
somewhat obvious to you if you imagine
each of these circles to be an ion you
could imagine these to be ionic solids
that we've seen that type of lattice
structure if you imagine each of these
circles to be atoms that are forming
covalent bonds with neighboring circles
then you could imagine this being a
covalent Network solid if you imagine
each of these circles are molecules and
due to intermolecular forces they have
arranged in this regular way to the
other molecules then you could imagine
this is a molecular solid you could also
imagine that each of these are metal
atoms and they're all sharing the soup
of valence electrons and so we are
dealing with a metallic solid but no
matter which visualization you use or
what you're imagining this to be it's
pretty clear that this is a solid and
one of the major giveaways of that is
that it's not taking the shape of the
container these molecules I guess you
could say these particles aren't able to
fully slide past each other and take the
shape of the container that they're in
which would happen in a liquid and
they're clearly not able to overcome the
forces between the particles to then go
off and do their own thing which we
would see in a gas and bounce around the
entire container so this is clearly a
solid now this one on the bottom left
here it does look like the part of
are taking the shape of the container
they are able to slide past each other
but there are still intermolecular
forces there that keep them from flying
apart so this is clearly a liquid and in
this bottom right quadrant you could
imagine what's going on
these particles whether they're
molecules or ions they have for the most
part been able to overcome the
intermolecular forces between them and
so they are just bouncing around fully
taking the form of the container that
they are in and so this is a gas now
what about this right over here it looks
kind of like a solid and that it's not
taking the shape of its container but
it's also irregular the way that you
might expect a liquid to be at least at
a snapshot in time and this because it's
not taking the shape of its container
and because these molecules or these
particles even though they are irregular
they aren't sliding past each other like
you would expect in a liquid this too is
a solid but we call this an amorphous
solid it does not have this nice
crystalline structure like we've seen
with the crystalline solids and there's
a lot of examples of a morphus solids
most of the solids you know in your life
that are stretchy that have an elastic
quality to them are amorphous solids for
example if you had a little bunch of
natural rubber you could pull on it and
it might look something like this when
you stretch it but then when you let go
it will go back to its original state or
maybe close to its original state and
the reason why it does that is natural
rubber is made up of polymers and just
to imagine what a polymer is this is a
molecular structure of actual natural
rubber it's a chain of carbons that are
bonded to hydrogen's and if you imagine
it if you were to zoom out from this you
imagine these change these very long
chains of carbons with hydrogen's and
then in natural rubber they all get
tangled up with each other and so they
are forming this amorphous solid it
doesn't look exactly like this
particulate model we just saw it's more
just imagine a bunch of strings that are
all tangled up and so if you were to
pull on them they are able to stretch
then you let go they get back to close
to where they were before now rubber
isn't the only polymer for example the
plastics you see all around you are also
polymers and a few are mostly amorphous
and then a few are mostly crystalline
and a lot are what we would call semi
crystalline which means they have both
amorphous and crystalline regions